bonjour à tous le cerveau il est au
centre de nos raisonnements de nos
actions et pourtant on en a aucune
perception sensible
je viens de l'inria ou des chercheurs en
mathématiques et en informatique
développe des méthodes pour mieux
observer nous comprendre le cerveau et
interagir avec lui on concède déjà
beaucoup de choses sur le cerveau mais
en réalité chacun de nos cerveaux et
bien particulier ses propres
spécificités
déjà au niveau de sa forme
de même que nous avons tous des corps
différents par leur morphologie le
cerveau également des décisions qui sont
caractéristiques à chaque personne
ensuite au niveau de son organisation
fonctionnelle il ya des grands principes
partagés par tous nos cerveaux par
exemple les aires visuelles qui situés à
l'arrière les airs sensori motrice au
centre les airs auditive dans les zone
temporale mais les contours précis de
césaire leur taille également dépendre
de notre histoire de la façon dont le
cerveau s'est construit au cours de
notre croissance et des activités que
nous avons pu mener qui nous sont
propres
donc chacun de nos cerveaux est digne
d'être explorées comme une terra
incognita pour mener cette exploration
on va cartographier le cerveau
c'est-à-dire savoir précisément dans un
cerveau individuel
quelles sont les zones qui correspondent
à des actions bien précises
et lorsque ces zones seront repérés on
pourra même aller observer l'activité
qui a lieu dans ces zones savoir la
caractérise et même la détecter
pour partir dans cette exploration on a
besoin d'un bagage notre bagage c'est un
appareil de mesure qui est vieux de près
d'un siècle mais qui continue chaque
jour à nous révéler les secrets de cet
organe donc c'est l'électro
encéphalogramme qui consiste en des
électrodes qu'on place sur le cuir
chevelu et que mesurent l'activité
électrique des neurones à la surface du
cerveau qu'ils émettent lorsqu'ils
communiquent entre eux donc cette
surface du cerveau bon imaginons que ce
soit comme un globe terrestre accord
d'activité des habitants seraient
représentés par des zones plus ou moins
lumineuse selon leur degré de
communication d'activité et nos
électrodes sont comme les satellites
autour de la terre qui observe
l'activité des axes des habitants donc
les neurones mais à une échelle assez
grossières alors comment faire pour
partir de mesures telles que celles
offertes par l'électro encéphalogramme
arrivé à cartographier des zones
correspondant à des activités précises
alors qu'on en a des mesures qui
finalement sont éloignés et qui viennent
une superposition de la superposition de
toutes ses activités de toutes les
heures en fait parce qu'elles sont
diffusées par tous les tissus qui sépare
le cerveau du cuir chevelu et bien
pourquoi résoudre un tel problème qui
paraît épineux les mathématiques offre
une solution
elle offre des solutions quand on a des
équations et des inconnus et les
inconnus c'est la répartition de
l'activité électrique à la surface du
cerveau les équations ce sont les
principes physiques qui relie cette
activité électrique ses activités les
unes aux autres et qui relie l'activité
aux mesures alors pour prendre un
exemple beaucoup plus simple imaginez
que je vous donne un porte-monnaie et je
vous dis la somme totale d'argent qui
contient est ce que vous pouvez en
déduire la répartition exacte des pièces
et des billets non
mais si je vous dis qu'il contient le
nombre minimal de pièces et de billets
pour arriver à cette somme alors oui il
ya une unique solution celle qu'utilise
la caissière ou le caissier quand il
vous rend la monnaie alors avec des
principes comme celui ci c'est à dire
les parties principe de simplicité ou
des connaissances a priori on rajoute au
problème on peut trouver une solution à
la cartographie c'est à dire repérer
quelles sont les zones qui s'activent
dans un cerveau à partir des mesures
faites sur l'électro encéphalogramme
mais cette cartographie est
individualisé pour un cerveau bien
particulier ce type de travaux peuvent
aider un chirurgien s'il s'agit d'un
patient a localisé dans un cerveau des
zones pathologique qui communique mal
qu'il faudra peut être opéré et repérées
autour de ces zones des régions
éloquente qui elle communique bien et
qu'il faut absolument préserver à partir
d'une cartographie on peut aussi
s'intéresser à analyser l'activité qui a
lieu c'est à dire grâce à l'électro
encéphalogramme on a des signaux donc
une bonne résolution temporelle on peut
observer l'activité comme un film à la
surface de cerveau est certes ces zones
convoi s'activer contiennent de nombreux
neurones qui ne sont pas forcément des
sifi qu'à une seule action
mais si on demande à une personne de
répété de nombreuses fois une seule
action comme par exemple bouger son bras
droit
on va pouvoir filtrer dans les mesures
ce qui correspond toujours à ce
mouvement du bras droit et en filtraient
toutes les autres activités cérébrales
qui n'ont pas de rapport avec l'action
et ainsi on peut identifier ou sans des
aires cérébrales
quel est le type de dynamique qui est
spécifique d'une certaine activité
une fois qu'on sait déterminer la nature
de l'activité correspondant à certaines
actions
il devient possible
blain de la détecter au moment même où
elle est en train d'être effectués en
temps réel ça ça amène la possibilité
d'ouvrir de nouvelles voies de
communication entre le cerveau et son
environnement
si on traduit cette détection on a un
autre langage commandes et cette
nouvelle voie de communication ne passe
pas forcément par les muscles alors
l'activité cérébrale on en parle depuis
tout à l'heure
prenons un exemple de caisse qui peut
déclencher une activité cérébrale
par exemple vous êtes à un feu rouge
dans votre voiture et vous attendait le
feu vert bien le moment où le feu vert
apparaît déclenché une activité très
spécifique dans votre cerveau
c'est une activité qui dit ah c'est ce
que j'attendais elle arrive 300
millisecondes après le signal lumineux
et on l'appelle londe p300 et bien ce
type de signal de réponse à une série
d'activités de en réponse un signal
attendu
nous l'avons utilisé dans un expérience
avec des patients au chu de nice l'an
dernier pour leur permettent de
communiquer pour cela nous leur avons
proposé une interface qui était composé
d'un clavier dont les lettres allaient
flashé sur l'écran donc en fait à chaque
flash de la lettre vous voyez le flash
et air au départ un petit smiley chaque
fois que la lettre que la personne veut
et peut les flashs ça déclenche cette
activité du feu vert à ces la lettre que
je voulais tabou
donc nous avons testé cette interface
avec des patients qui étaient atteintes
de la maladie de charcot qui est une
maladie
neuro dégénératives du motoneurone ses
neurones qui relie le cerveau aux
muscles et qui donc rendre peu à peu les
les patients incapables parfois
d'articuler de bouger leurs membres et
parfois même les deux à la fois et nos
partenaires hospitalier au chu de nice
cherche des moyens alternatifs de
communication pour ces personnes dont le
cerveau est empêché de fonctionner en
émissions par contre leur cerveau est
parfaitement opérationnel en ce qui
concerne les tâches cognitives et la
réception donc ici la patiente vous que
vous voyez à en-tête le mot rêver
rebell74 c si vivement sur chacune des
lettres du mot qu'elle veut taper et
elle compte dans sa tête le nombre de
fois que la lettre qu'elle veut et pelé
est en train de flasher à chacun de ces
signaux de la bonne lettre en détectent
londe p300 dans son cerveau donc
regardons la lettre e qui est la
troisième en partant du haut 1 2 3 4
donc cette patiente au bout de quatre ou
cinq flush de la lettre voit que le
système a réussi à décoder la lettre sur
laquelle elle porter son attention
visuelle donc des patients ou leurs
familles nous en demander mais est ce
que c'est vous travaillez sur la
télépathie en fait
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez est
ce que c'est la télépathie non on est
réellement en train de décoder quelque
chose dans le cerveau des patients c'est
une information qui nous dit elle vient
de percevoir le signale qu'elle
attendait elle vient de percevoir la
bonne lettre mais on n'est pas en train
de décoder dans le cerveau des patients
la lettre exact qu'ils étaient bons à
laquelle il était en train de penser ce
serait possible si on avait des
enregistrements à une échelle plus fine
que celle offerte par l'électro
encéphalogramme pour cela il faudrait
aller placer des électrodes
directement dans le cerveau alors pour
terminer cette exploration
je vais vous proposer un petit détour
dans le monde de l'imagination
lorsqu'on veut exécuter des mouvements
complexes
c'est utile de se les représenter
mentalement à l'avance c'est une
technique qui a été employé par des
grands sportifs par exemple jean claude
killy pour augmenter ses performances
mais il n'ya pas que les sportifs qui
peuvent vouloir augmenter leurs
performances
prenons l'exemple d'un patient atteint
d'un avc qui seraient dans l'incapacité
de bouger son bras et tend son bras
droit en fait si cette personne
n'imagine bouger son bras droit s'est
déclenché une activité cérébrale qui est
très semblable à celle obtenue si le
bouger réellement avec les techniques
dont on vient de parler si on est
capable de bien caractérisé cette
activité qui produisent par l'image et
le son motrices on est capable de la
détecter mais au moment même où la
personne est en train d'imaginer donc on
peut se servir de cette information là
il a transformé en une action réelle en
équipe son bras d'un immortel motorisés
qui va déclencher le mouvement que la
personne n'arrive plus à déclencher
elles mêmes à chaque fois qu'elle
imagine le bouger et bien voyons cela le
cerveau du patient va être amené à
développer des nouvelles connexions qui
vont peu à peu lui permettre de
récupérer le mouvement
peu à peu on pourra dès diminué
l'assistance électrique et le patient se
réappropriera le contrôle de son propre
bras
donc c'est une nouvelle forme de
kinésithérapie qui se sert du cerveau
l'activité cérébrale qui est à l'étude
et des études cliniques en ce sens
actuellement donc qui consiste à
transformer de l'imagination en actions
ont donc on a vu dans cette brève
exploration
que la cartographie permet de
caractériser des zones qui s'activent
dans le cerveau de manière individuelle
personnalisés etc on peut même aller
regarder la dynamique de l'activité du
cerveau pour mieux la comprendre
l'interpréter et même la traduire en
action réelle
alors je vous invite à toujours
continuer d'imaginer ce que vous avez
envie de faire parce que le fait
d'imaginer les choses les mets à votre
portée